this is bottomless pit' what the fuck
are you doing
it's the holidays I thought I would like
pull a Mabel see I got like the ugly
sweater with the actually it says take
me gnome tonight so it's very do you
know what shut up I'm in the spirit
right here plug me in I won't plug you
in I'll give you the means but not
actually do it all right you ready for
this
ahh didn't work oh let's do that again
yeah ahh you're the complete package so
are you just gonna like that yeah why
not it back you're gonna like destroy
your back yeah that's why I'm not gonna
sit back oh wait I do the waddle sing as
well that's that really is adorable
mm-hmm adorable terrifying which is just
the robbed experience it's just adorably
rattle waddles yes
Appa waddles okay so what enables my
favorite character I can enjoy in the
Christmas spirit even not with up but
it's a different show it's a different V
log show damn it they all then get a
frickin waddles for christmas okay I'll
get you one for fucking Christmas thank
you anywho okay this is bottomless pit
and this is uh Oh first of all what's
that the opening is uh so she doesn't
say like Rob across it and then I see
why she wore it inside out it's a boar
which is more appropriate hi oh yeah I
went there Shazam boy ye yeah you know
what dipper just because I'm in the
spirit doesn't know wait I mean you know
what Duncan shit that is we want to cry
oh uh yeah
yeah well that said let's actually get
to the episode uh first of all the
message at the end is it says next up
foot BOTS to grunkle avenge which why we
want revenge he won the football ball
which he that that makes me think
because he says like the football bowl
and like here's the football bowl big
trophy with the foot bonza I'm wondering
cuz you see him watching that old black
and white chick flick I'm wondering if
like he's ever actually seen a game a
football and like he's just saying to
himself like this is what guys like so
this is what I should like I don't know
guess he never said Super Bowl or I
think he just saw it fall ball and all
that stuff obviously it's like someone
who has never actually watched football
Wow on the subject um I will say we're
stupid because like of course since we
film these um two weeks ago I think we
start here and they've been more than
that three three or four weeks ago and
they've been running now for about a
week and a half everything it stands for
great uncle Stan it's great uh cos dad
god damn you okay went up it says that
somebody wrote yes somebody sent me a
thing that's just like you know you know
they said it in this line and they post
the line as I am surprised you missed
that it's like you know maybe the second
line in the whole thing is like we're
going to a place called gravity falls
with our great uncle's day and blah blah
blah and it's like that's it I mean
that's like the one thing we have and
it's like yeah okay we missed it but
it's like one line that goes pass really
you know really quick so on it I
honestly I like our theory bed I like
drop you better yeah like grumpy uncle
sand a lot better cuz it's way more
descriptive of what he is but I never so
we said its grumpy uncle stare it's
great uncle stare should be grumpy uncle
it's great uncle Stan and because this
will be probably premiering what five
six seven days from now if someone yeah
I'll just sit here and have to read
another seven days of it yeah it won't
be as bad as the one say you know that
time traveler was in the episodes it's
like shit
okay that wife um I was in there let's
make something very clear cuz people
have gone to my facebook it's like you
know the time to ever get paid you mean
it and I'm like don't look at me this is
the first time I don't got that this is
the absolute first time I wasn't even
looking for any of that am i trying to
find something shiny orderliness that
totally there but I found some
interesting stuff in this one uh not
much but some interesting stuff uh
alright so they fall down this
bottomless pit they're getting rare
stuff they don't want and then one of
the best Mabel wines ever just my
mysterious box of personal secrets
nothing to see here um and they fall
down it and they get bored so they
decide to tell stories it's kind of an
anthology of stories and one is about
dippers voice which is very appropriate
we've may follow that voice for now be
fun oh no no no y'all know what the
ultimate irony is this is literally the
first episode where his voice from the
get-go didn't bother me and then it's
all about how we're deceased it's I've
gotten used to it alas and then they're
pointing out out where this voice is I'm
like oh come on right when I get it did
they plan it that way cuz seriously I'm
just finally this like you know what you
know it's the voices all right is that
it and I'm just like and now they're
making fun of it so he goes to the crazy
old man mcgucket or whatever his name is
uh who's still an adventure which this
is I'm watching it a second time like
him being an inventor actually does come
into play later which it's neat seeing
them set this up who gives him this man
was an adventure to begin with he did
build a giant's no no I know but it's
something where it's like it's not like
just a hobby like oh hey he's a fight
he's an adventurer there actually is a
backstory to it they get to later um but
so he has this he gives them this voice
potion or scientific whatever and
nothing suspiciously like a cross
between Lionel's Space Ghost and Gary oh
yes uh Gary always west face ghost um
but we actually felt was Gary always but
then we're just like it's even still
alive it was your Space Ghost and Space
Ghost Coast to Coast no no no he was the
original yeah the original space yeah um
so and we looked it up the guy's just
like he's just absurd
you know voiceover Aria totally nuts cuz
I thought wow this sounds so familiar
yeah he only has like ten credits to his
name or something like that which on the
one hand I'm Cal like oh I wish they got
someone you know bigger name by the
other hand like no cool you know that
they're getting some new talent in there
and this is like a real good showcase
for him and he was really funny I mean
really funny
a Smith Harrison I think is what he's
even when I cry I sound ridiculous so he
goes back to having his normal voice so
that's the first story second story um
uh is the pinball Wang where soos and
Mabel and dipper gets sucked into a
pinball machine uh would I need somebody
to act distracting and annoying and loud
my time has come
uh which is one of those were it's like
like watching is that like I laugh super
hard or anything but like although there
were a few times but have you ever
played a pinball game when you're
looking just be like god I wish I could
run around in there like cuz they make
it look so entertaining I mean like The
Simpsons one was amazing did you want to
walk through that pinball game decisons
one all those movie ones from like the
early nineties yeah Star Wars the
addressing large essex finely sell park
what is great so it's like really cuz
i'll no pinball games are really done
anymore but like they used to put a shit
ton of detail onto these and you did
kind of want to walk around in them so
this was a great set up for that cuz i'm
like i'm sure somewhere like people
don't like a point of view in a pinball
machine or something like that but i
don't know like this one scene just i I
do both Zeus's little moments just
hushed exclamation of wonder
um and so they go through their suits of
course learns a lesson as well about
like you know keeping his high score and
everything and then the last one is
about the truth damn it the truth and
Mabel finds these magic teeth or I
forget where they are they're made out
of something that told the truth which I
remember now um they make it they just
make you tell ya Wonder Woman's lasso
only it's false teeth yeah it sounds
weird when you say that and their goal
to
actually I just realized yes that's
really weird uh maybe Italian to Wonder
Woman somehow tie and tie lasso rope it
so know what save it for the bedroom
down so when they go uh so she is tired
of Stan lying so she because he throw
for a you wanted teach a beer today or a
bid is one of the funniest things I've
seen in the cartoon ever just when he
rolls them window down there's a bear
there what seems to be the problem
officer
well I can't argue with dr. Bredesen all
right we gotta get going yeah he's in
the hospital they're wrong I mean - oh
my god like three really strong great
jokes after another and that oh it's the
surreal non sequiturs they make it just
so um so Mabel gets these teeth they
have stayin tell the truth and because
she thinks there's never telling the
truth is always a good thing it's never
wrong and stayin tells the truth too
many times gets them in trouble the
point that I think they're threatening
suicide yeah yeah a little bit about
just like are we just waiting for the
sweet release of death is this all there
is this is like oh god oh god oh god
that especially I think it's the best
example um you know of just when telling
the truth cannot be good uh and so
finally she lies in the end to sort of
get them out of this predicament and she
feels really a shame and then finally at
the end the black hole just throws them
out on the other side and Stan falls
back in again I love to the bits just in
the black hole like when Mabel's like
using dipper as a log and like yeah and
then grunkle Stan sign dippers pain is
fun but I feel this isn't gonna last one
you know the story he makes up about the
football bowl or thank you for inventing
me Father I love you um but you don't
fight when I first saw this house or
turned off by the fact that it was a my
apology
uh but watch it again it's actually much
better than I remember it I like a lot
you know it's because they do another
one next season which i think is even
better
nah it's an even better setup uh and but
no watching this one again else are like
bottomless pit oh yeah that's right they
tell the stories I don't really remember
the stories are but yeah for some reason
watching it a second time I'm like the
is much better than I remember Oh the
lifeguard by the way is in the bar um he
shows up in our episode I use one of the
tough guys um you'll see later uh but
the big thing I like about this one is
so many kid shows and you can't fault
them too much by somebody kitchen always
tell the truth never lie it so it's got
and the moral is really sometimes lines
okay yes and that's a good moral and
don't get me wrong
kids don't know when to lie yet so let's
of course a somewhat unless of course
it's an avatar and you're meeting a
bunch of people through a canyon yeah
well that's a wrong time to lie you know
I mean it's it's one of those things
where it's like there is a right there
is a time to lie but it one of those we
do an impossible standard of absolutes
how can you disagree with avatar but
agree here it but like the one that you
point out with him like questioning life
and depressing dipper and Mabel it's
like we I'm sure everybody gets thoughts
like that guy what look at your ugly
Freddy's yeah I mean it's like there are
time to either keep the truth or lie and
so on and so forth and I've know people
that adults are just like if there's
never a right time to lie always tell
the truth like always and it's not
healthy I mean there are times where you
need to keep stuff away to help move
forward help yourself help others
whatever uh so lying any even film it's
it's an illusion it's a deception and
stuff like that so we can get sucked in
I mean we know it's not really happening
but I mean that there's big aspects to
deception and illusion or like twincest
I could have lied and said it didn't
exist but you didn't I know cuz I was
being honest like Mabel would have want
but you should it's the Mabel flew
another day you should have lied about
that well on a similar note if it makes
you feel any better a bunch of fans
tried to punish me by saying you think
that's bad you should see something
called dipper goes to Taco Bell so I
recommend you go see Dipper goes toot I
am avoiding dipper goes in time and when
you do here take this with you
oh this is really really good stuff you
may want to take this to peppermint
schnapps will make you forget do they
man and enjoy uh yeah sure why not
go
okay um so yeah still a um so I really
like the moral of that one the most um
but I probably like the the dipper voice
probably made me laugh the hardest no I
take a bag actually the the truth when
to make the landfire is just cuz of the
bear the bear is amazing the bear was
amazing um so yeah like so my first
thought I didn't think that much of it
but something about the second time it's
uh it's actually a really really good
episode uh and I really enjoyed it uh
your phone's cheat oh okay you just
wanted to wear a sweater you yeah like
pretty much just like pretty much yeah
okay so um we'll see you next episode uh
maybe after dipper goes to talk about
I'm not watching that but you can well
please please do watch it cuz I haven't
watched it I don't wanna watch it either
I'll tell you what I don't want to watch
it they said dipper goes to Taco Bell
and I'm like yeah that has nothing in it
they can be good I don't like talk about
it'll be good is it even like really a
fan maybe someone just made it up
eighties naivete me it doesn't know
because enough different people like
other people just like oh my god dipper
goes to talk about you oh no oh no and
I'm just like yeah I know enough like to
be like I don't need to see this okay
well we're not Cabella they spring meat
out of a hose oh I'm sorry not a hose a
cock gun they spray need out of a cop
gun everything you're saying is just
leading to this horrible possibility of
what dipper goes to talk about could be
III can I can't imagine I'm liking so
you watch it have a scotch and then let
me know I'll tell you what I did
twincest for you okay I suffer you
didn't twincest how you did twinsen let
me rephrase that
yeah but may might be a good idea I
looked it up because the fans told me
about it don't blame the messenger by
the way it was your stupid fans that
sent me all this twincest shit i love
the fact that it's like so in this video
we have you saying I did twincest and I
love Mabel pretty much I'm just gonna
take those flights in together while in
this getup
yeah but I'm dressed as maple so I can't
do Mabel being dressed as Mabel really I
would have had to have said I did dipper
in which case that would be you and this
got awfully awkward
see a Taco Bell